Oh
I didn't say anything I just leaned out
of the kitchen showed him the jar and
right there next to his girl ah you
[Music]
welcome it is not happening I'm your
host Ari Shaffir today all the stories
are about karma a veteran of the show
you guys are seeing her to see the
YouTube clips you've seen this guy he's
absolutely hilarious I'm glad he's back
please give it up for my friend of yours
mr. Shawn Mac my first ever apartment
was in New Orleans in the year 2002 my
roommate and I paid five hundred and
thirty five dollars even not
individually one lump sum all utilities
included a two-bedroom two-bath to
balcony apartment and I still remember
like confronting our landlord
okay can you shave off that extra five
give us a chance to survive
and I we move I moved in I think
everyone's first roommate is a friend
mine was not I went to high school with
this guy didn't really know him we moved
in in the morning because it was all his
nothing was mine I don't know if anyone
has that roommate or is that roommate
like you got the couch you have the TV
you have the table I have the mattress
and the box that I will reuse but the
previous tenant had left us a gift okay
now by round of applause who is not
familiar with what is known as tony
satter 'is not familiar enough tony
satter ease it's a Creole spice it's
like Louisiana New Orleans version of an
old bay it's a you put you know you put
it on old tennis shoe and make a tail
you like a fillet gumbo you know how say
y'all you put it on rub and sandwich
make it a like a shrimp po-boy montalais
ol side no way let's put the story aside
for a second that's a really
annoying thing about being from southern
Louisiana is people like but where's
your accent like they want you all
knocked out black day the other day I
went down there Gator huntin and I cut
me open alligator and it stung me with
full of crawdads it was full of crawdads
dude with hardened from Hurricane
Katrina like that stone done going on a
crawl - and then that Gator came back to
life bit my hand off like I was Captain
Hook Jesus
I had a drop too and it dropped in the
hospital with no hand drinking beers and
the sheriff gonna put me off on a boat
he pulled me on a damn boat
I said sheriff I got a boat on land he
said I did you got your truck in the
water there's LA Manzana Lake
I'm disappointed too I wish I spoke like
that truthfully a true New Orleans
accent just sounds like take a
East Coast guy why are you asking around
from well is it your business I'm from
Hoboken take that guy
give him a valium now you got in the
wall his accent I don't remember where
I'm from
what's the Hoboken you can fish on it
all right back to the story so the
previous tenant left behind a gift for
us it wasn't Tony Satter ease I just
like talking about that stuff is
delicious but it was a spice he left
behind a jar of cumin right cumin you
know it it's very con you've ever had a
curry or a chili it's if you if you
tasted chili you've tasted cumin and
there's a little secret if you if you're
broke and you got a hot dog but you
can't afford a chili just sprinkle some
cumin on that hot dog it'll make it
taste exactly like you rolled it in dirt
it's not a good standalone spikes at all
it really isn't
that's probably why he left it behind
but upon discovering that jar I said to
my new roommate hey look at this big-ass
jar of cumin
it spelled cumi n and I know how it's
pronounced but first of all coming it's
like an ejaculation joke and I was in my
early 20s when ejaculation jokes were
very funny now in my 30s ejaculation
jokes are extremely funny they've gotten
funnier but also one of my favorite gags
is to purposely mispronounce things
because I love rousing the grammar
dragons and that's your teeth grammar
dragon hey look at this big-ass jar of
cumin
I expected him tell you know worst case
be like shut up it's pronounced cumin or
who knows best case now we got a new
inside joke between roommates that we
can have for the next six months unless
we extend at least a year you know so I
said it hey look at this big-ass jar
coming and he goes what what it's cumin
goddamnit it's cumin don't say that
exactly
Oh Oh
whom did I just move in with and now I
was obsessed with that moment and before
I knew it it was lunchtime and he
ordered a Hawaiian pizza and I was like
oh Hawaiian pizza
you know it's delicious when you put it
on Hawaiian pizza
some common and right away like
clockwork
seriously don't say that to me
again it's cumin you say right you'll
say and then grow up I was like well now
I'm never going to grow up come on
you just Peter Pan to me I am a boy for
life laid it later that day his
girlfriend comes over it's like evening
time it's our first time the new
apartment they're sharing a pint of ice
cream and I didn't even I didn't even
say anything I just leaned out of the
kitchen showed them the jar
and right there next to his girl he's
off you
and she's of course like huh well and he
explained it
he did his funny to pronounce human come
him and then she starts laughing because
she has a sense of humor and then he
turns on harlech god damn a duck got
five it's killed him and he's yelling
and I didn't see much of her after that
and I had to leave because their fight
got pretty loud and pretty awkward and I
went out drinking with friends and where
I'm like you got to see this you got to
see this and I bring them back to
the apartment it's like 3:30 in the
morning oh hey welcome to the new digs
fellas can I offer you some Ritz
crackers and comment then like clockwork
he comes out of his room hey what the
I've killed it say it say it and
we're all laughing our ass off yeah I
hope you all die one day
well we will nice one nice one man and
all he had to do was just not react just
once then I'd have forgotten about it
but now I had no choice I was having
dreams about how I was gonna mess with
them and so next morning were both up
early I knew in our first day in the new
apartment first morning okay he's up
early cuz he was still in class in
school he had to go to class I'm up
early to go to work
and he's sitting down to a fresh plate
of scrambled eggs and I was like hey you
know it would be delicious on those
scrambled eggs and it gives me a look
that I can only describe as murder
- look you give someone when you want to
murder them and then sexually violate
their dead body so their soul can't go
to heaven murder it looks like so
he gives me that look so I know I can't
say coming go throw a knuckleball at him
so I said some Tony surgeries I bought
some last nights in the kitchen and
anyone from like ah Oh smiling because
that would have Tony satton made you do
it
he's so delicious ha ha ha you put it on
a crazy person turn him into a friend Oh
Shante
now he is in the kitchen digging around
and I hear him opening and closing all
the cabinets
where is it oh it's in the it's in the
cabinet which one the one above the
George Foreman grill where I can't find
it it's in the top part there we're
behind the common and what normally
followed that word as I established was
a fit of rage
only this time that's not what happened
this time it was total silence which was
scary cuz after a while I was like oh
god am I gonna walk in there and find
him just on the crown with his wrists
slit bleeding it out you went too far
went too far it's pronounced human and
now you'll never forget Oh Lord I'm
trouble
thankfully no that's not what happened
instead he comes out holding the jar
staring me down with the hatred of a
thousand men and then throws it at me
because he just didn't it was it was
like he just released too early and it
bounced off the wall and just landed
like right there between us on the
carpet and I look up at him and he's now
crying hatred hatred tears you can tell
in their hatred tears because they're
boiling with rage and they evaporate
mid-cheek and he says oh I'm going to
class and then I'm moving out
and he storms off now I had just been
attacked for no reason first order of
business in that moment is to eat those
scrambled eggs they were fresh and I was
hungry and I doused him with that Tony's
it was right there by the microwave I'm
surprised he didn't find it second order
of business call into work sick I
couldn't bus tables I was traumatized I
couldn't handle silverware in that
mental state third order of business a
little well-deserved R&R plopped down on
the couch his couch mind you turn the TV
on his TV didn't know if any that stuff
was gonna be there by the end of the day
watching TV oh look a Saved by the Bell
marathon oh wow
season three while they're at the Malibu
Sands beach resort oh they're in bikinis
well I've earned this a little release
and there I am furiously masturbating on
his couch watching his TV and right as I
near climax that jar catches my eye it's
still laying there on the ground and now
I am that's why I was in this moment so
it was like a lover to me and I
exclaimed Oh
woman right as I began coming and I
shouted it so the furniture window was
going on and then the front door swung
open and there's a UPS delivery guy
standing there holding a package sees me
holding my package and says oh no
and slams that door a couple of things
yes he caught me masturbating by but he
scared me frightened me and it happened
right as I began orgasming have you ever
been frightened right as you begin to
come oh man is it great oh man is it so
badass oh it's so much semen you forth
from my loins I don't know what happens
maybe your brain senses danger and
orders a mandatory full evacuation of
your testicles well in that way go save
the seed the mothership is in danger
there was so much and then I just had to
sit there quietly like is he still is he
still there Oh God I finally went and
looked out of the people and yep he's
standing there
sort of swaying and I was like god
dammit ah so I lit a cigarette thought
it would make me look more badass lit a
cigarette
okay they open the door and right away
he's like listen I'm not in a no goddamn
gay I got a wife I got a family and
you're too young I know right wife
what's that for
but now I'm defensive with puffing on my
cigarette like hey man it's a
private apartment why don't you try
knocking you ever heard of knocking then
he doesn't say anything and angrily goes
I didn't not because you said come in
because you
that's the kind of coincidence that made
man invent God if I were a religious
person that would have been my mindset
like well the Lord clearly does not want
me touching myself thus why he sent this
brave soldier to interrupt me whilst
doing the devil's diddle like I couldn't
stop like in that moment like he was
about to knock I didn't say come in I
was having sex with a spice I said Oh
cumin what sounds exactly like Oh God
gee all I could think about in that
moment was my roommate he's right I
should have pronounced it correctly if
I'd have been like Oh cumin he'd heard
that into like what he saying oh shoot I
should knock
and I would later find out by the way
the reason my roommate got so pissed is
because as his childhood pet was a
cocker spaniel named cumin and so when I
said comment it reminded of cumin and he
got said that I was mispronouncing it
you
and then this UPS guy he slams his
clipboard in my chest
he's I have to sign for it and now I'm
just backpedaling I'm like look I
thought you were my girlfriend and
heater up to me he's like you ain't got
no damn girlfriend
I do not Metheny gives me the package
says have a nice day and then finally I
looked finally look at the package it
wasn't addressed to me it was not
addressed to my roommate it was
addressed to who I assumed was the
previous tenant so that meant is
addressed to me now and I open it and
almost collapse at what I see before me
can you guess no there's a spice rack
if the previous moment made me believe
in God that made me believe that God is
capable of bragging thank you guys very
much
[Music]
you